I'd like to take a moment to thank all
of the generous sponsors who made who
made tonight's episode possible
tonight's episode of the Pete home show
was brought to you by cheap ass
umbrellas that's right cheap ass
umbrellas guaranteed to surprise the
out of you when it suddenly inverts
like an exasperated bony man throwing
his arms up like I'm
out thanks cheap ass umbrellas tonight's
episode was also brought to you by the
guy who gets mad when you don't love the
same movie he
loves without you I'd never have known
that even though it put me to sleep Argo
is the most important film of Our
Generation thanks guy who gets mad when
you don't love the same movie He
Loves